president Trump suggests the Senate 10
and the shutdown by killing the
filibuster the president tweeted
yesterday that Republicans should go to
51% nuclear option changing the Senate
rule that requires 60 votes to end
debate chip Reid is at the White House
with more on this chip good morning well
good morning
Republicans on Capitol Hill rejected the
president's suggestion of using the
nuclear option and so far the president
has been unable to convince the key
players to agree to a compromise that
would keep the government open we do not
want to shut down Office of Management
and Budget director Mick Mulvaney argued
Sunday that Democrats forced the
shutdown to trip up the president it's
pure but it was a Trump campaign ad that
proved a distraction Democrats who stand
in our way will be complicit in every
murder committed by illegal immigrants
both parties distanced themselves I
don't know if that's necessarily
productive it is really unbelievable
President Trump had no public
appearances this weekend only consulting
by phone with cabinet members and
congressional leaders we could not
answer your call today the White House
comments line unstaffed because of the
shutdown said this congressional
Democrats are holding government funding
including funding for our troops and
other national security priorities
hostage to an unrelated immigration
debate I essentially agreed to give the
president something he has said he wants
in exchange for something we both want
Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
said it was the president who changed
his mind after the two men reached a
deal on daca and border security during
a meeting Friday he backed away from the
last best chance to avoid a shutdown in
2013 mr. Trump criticized then President
Obama for failing to lead the country
out of a shutdown we have to be a leader
the president has to lead and
unfortunately he's never been a
dealmaker House Speaker Paul Ryan said
the president needs to find a firm
negotiating position I guess the
question is the question is where's the
President on this issue is that n is he
going to stay in one place yeah so I
think it's I think what president should
do is leave room for negotiation to get
a solution that's exactly what he's
doing
South Carolina Republican Lindsey Graham
singled out White House advisors
Stephen Miller claiming that Miller
hardline views on immigration are making
it very difficult to reach a deal and
calling him quote an outlier a White
House spokesman fired back saying Graham
is the outlier and accusing him of quote
siding with people in this country
illegally instead of with Americans gal
oh boy thank you chip